Hey guys!
Today is an awesome day,
well actually, in truth, every day
is an awesome day right?
Because every day
is a gift from God.
And we canboldly say that;
"This is the day
that the Lord has made,
I will rejoice and
I will be glad in it."
You see, you need to choose
to live in that truth.
and you know, we as Christians,
we knowthat
life only starts to make sense
when we find God.
And then to abide in Him,
He in us andwe in Him.
And if you want to share
that with the world,
being bold, not ashamed,
then do that.
Do it with the Merch!
This is a great way of sharing the gospel,
it arrived today,
FoundGod?
And I'm going to wear it boldly,
I'm not going to be ashamed,
because we know that thegospel
has the power to save Souls.
So go, and be bold
and proclaim the kingdom of God.
Do it in love, in truth,
and through the Spirit!